expliquer le programme présenté les
propositions concrètes c'est l'objectif
de ces rencontres dans les quartiers de
la verrière nicolas dainville et son
équipe se présente aux élections
municipales avec trois priorités
l'éducation la sécurité et le cadre de
vie en porte les valeurs du mérite
on a envie de pousser tous ceux qui ont
envie de s'en sortir on a aussi des
valeurs de justice sociale on n'a pas
envie de laisser tomber ceux qui ont des
difficultés sociales
on a les valeurs je dirais de l'autorité
on a envie de plus de respect de
l'autorité
respect des aînés respect des parents
spd les éducateurs respect des règles
face aux 16 % de chômage sur la commune
la liste nouvelle dynamique pour la
verrière propose des mesures directement
aux demandeurs d'emploi on a deux
propositions fortes pour l'emploi c'est
du mentorat que des salariés saint
quentinois coach des jeunes virois et
puis on a envie de créer l'école de
commerce de la verrière pour transmettre
aux jeunes les codes de l'entreprise et
les faire réussir dans le monde
professionnel dans cette liste sans
étiquette des verriers rois et des
verrières oise
engagé politiquement vivant dans
différents quartiers ou issus de la
société civile
je suis maman je dis à la verrière et je
vois d'un moment aussi comment avec
leurs enfants
nous voulons par exemple au niveau de la
cantine du bio les aliments ou des menus
qui sont vraiment variés de qualité pour
nos enfants parce que c'est la vie dès
demain évidemment et au niveau de
l'école par exemple nouveau monde et
suivi des aides scolaires des aides
après l'école lors du premier et unique
tour des élections municipales de 2014
la lys porté par nicolas dainville avait
recueilli 40 % des voix le taux
d'abstention avait lui atteint les 45 %